this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist use the link in the
description to receive one free week and
25 off a premium membership
so much of what we believe we know is
based on what we have been told
you believe you know how time works how
other people think and feel what the
events of human history were what's
inside your body and how it works where
the earth is and how it moves what the
universe is and what particles comprise
it and so on unless you are an expert in
any of these areas and likely even still
your knowledge of these sorts of things
is based not on direct observation but
on what you have been told by other
people
what has been explained to you through
reason
when ideas and beliefs are not readily
testable within the purview of our
expertise or individual abilities we
reasonably turn to authority figures as
a means of forming understanding and
defending them
but how trustworthy is what we've been
told how trustworthy are we in properly
selecting who and what we listen to and
how trustworthy is reason in general
throughout human history primarily in
the realm of ideas and beliefs but still
often in the realm of tangible and
practical issues one of the few rare
truths that seems to have endured is the
fact that we are consistently very wrong
the authority figures and experts who
line human history individuals who had
the credibility and respect of their
time are now mostly seen and described
as smart for their time
what else is this notion smart for their
time if not a premonition of the
ignorance of our own
in an effort to choose good authority
figures and experts we likely consider
and listen to individuals with good
track records after all the more often
someone has been correct and validated
by culture about a particular subject
matter the more likely they will
continue to be
but if we consider their track record as
a member of humanity not limited to the
course of their individual lifetime but
considered against the course of
humanity's lifetime their track record
like everyone else's is almost certainly
destined to be a losing one
in peru in the middle of the 1400s there
was what is believed to be the largest
known child sacrifice in the world with
about 140 children and more than 200
animals killed
the reason attempting to appease the
gods in response to unusually bad
weather
in europe in the 17th century just a few
hundred years ago it was widely believed
that the earth was the center of the
universe and everything else revolved
around it when the now famous astronomer
galileo galilei published work that
showed that instead the sun was the
center of the universe and the earth
revolved around the sun which we of
course now know the latter to be true
the roman inquisition banned his work
and the arguments he put forth and
eventually tried and found galileo
vehemently suspect of heresy
others who came before and around his
time with similar now believed to be
true ideas were even put to death
in the late 19th century little more
than a hundred years ago doctors used
what are now schedule 1 narcotics to
treat cold symptoms in children also
around this time doctors believed it was
foolish to wash their hands before
delivering babies or during other
medical procedures
only 80 years ago it was believed that
cigarettes posed no health dangers still
to this day and thousands of years back
across the globe humans have believed
and still believe that the trade of
other humans for the non-consensual
exploitation of their labor is morally
permissible and the list goes on forward
and back
this earth is not merely a cemetery of
people that once were but also a
cemetery of ideas and beliefs once held
to be true but are no longer
to perhaps help illuminate how problems
within human reasoning and argumentation
can arise consider the following
syllogism
one flowers are beautiful
two a lilac is a flower
three
therefore lilacs are beautiful
the reasoning in this example is valid
and so the conclusion also appears to be
valid but it is not the premise begs the
question it postulates a conclusion that
is not sufficiently argued for and
cannot be sufficiently argued for in
objective terms although it is very
common to think that flowers are
beautiful whether or not all flowers are
beautiful is subjective it is a belief
that cannot be proven or disproven
and so this syllogism is fallacious and
it always will be
and yet it sounds very reasonable
arguably the realm of philosophy
politics morality sociology spirituality
and meaning in general areas in which we
cannot fully prove or disprove things
because they cannot be tested at
sufficient scale we cannot reach
inaccessible information needed and we
cannot know of all the possible
consequences or alternatives these
realms are seemingly fields filled with
these sorts of problems
most if not all ideas and arguments in
these realms are and must be based on
some sort of subjective presumptions
based off personal experience and
vantage points of the world not rigid
objective knowledge and thus notions of
what is right and wrong good and bad
best and worst like flowers being
beautiful or styles and dialects being
in fashion these things can change as
the zeitgeist of culture changes through
time and space
in their book the enigma of reason
cognitive scientists hugo mercier and
dan sperber hypothesized that the
ability to reason evolved in humans not
to make better decisions or be more
accurate about facts but to socialize
better to better provide explanations to
others about who we are what we do and
why we do what we do in order to improve
social standing and social cohesion
and so reason in this framework works as
a way of making intuitions and ideas the
most shareable and defendable not
necessarily the best or most objective
mercier and are right reason improves
our social standing rather than leading
us to intrinsically better decisions and
even when it leads us to better
decisions it's mostly because we happen
to be in a community that favors the
right type of decisions on the issue but
there is a potential for tension between
the lazy justification provided by
socially recognized good reasons and an
individual effort to better understand
and evaluate these reasons to acquire
some expertise oneself
upon birth we were all given a body a
mind a genetic makeup a pair of parents
present or not and a collection of
circumstances we did not choose any of
these things but fairly soon these
factors fan out and develop into our
world view
this worldview influences us to choose
and believe things which we then
associate with our identity
from here however we often wield reason
not as a method of moving toward truth
and out of the default beliefs disposed
onto us but rather a method of defending
and proving these beliefs we attempt to
prove that what we have come to find
ourselves believing was arrived at
fairly intellectually and rationally
that the flowers must be beautiful
objectively
the world is far more complicated
unclear and unknown than most of us
admit let alone know
there are perceptual tricks
psychological motivators and logical
fallacies that drench our minds and spew
out of our mouths
it is unclear if we are ever right in
any real sense at all let alone as often
as we think no one knows the
unforeseeable consequences of things and
no one knows the unknowable the
untestable or the unprovable
and so a blaringly obvious question that
emerges is
why do so many people act as if they do
moreover why are so many people who act
as if they do in important positions in
the world why do we simultaneously act
like and trust others that act like we
are not a species who has historically
always been wrong about nearly
everything still wielding the same dull
weapons of mind and reason
of course this is not to say that
nothing can be true in physical terms
that nothing can be improved or made
more accurate through the scientific
method and that we can arrive at
mutually useful subjective truths that
have immense social value
ultimately there's nothing wrong with
having opinions and beliefs and there's
nothing wrong with arguing for and
defending those opinions and beliefs but
if there is not some large base of
skepticism wedged at the bottom of them
the same sort of skepticism we likely
apply to others when we listen to their
beliefs and opinions we have assumed the
following we are somehow special that
our rationality is somehow always
superior in all these cases with all
these other people that we do not
possess the same propensity toward the
erroneous nature of presumptions of
biases and to faulty reasoning that
everyone we disagree with does
what is more likely we and the people
who agree with us are the only rational
and right ones in history or we just
like everyone else are probably wrong in
at least some sense
the history of humanity is a series of
failures on a seemingly never-ending
path toward unattainable absolute truth
we are no different we are each
infinitesimal appendages attached to
this body of ignorance stricken by our
own ignorance and limited to where we
reside on this body
arguably the best way to be the most
right the most often is to assume that
you are probably always some amount
wrong
after all if reason is potentially a
tool evolved out of the need to better
socialize then perhaps we can and should
if we agree use our reasoning to reduce
the intensity with which we wield reason
in other words perhaps we should use
reason to realize the limits of reason
to realize that the plights of us are in
others and the ignorance of others is in
us
to realize that we should try to be
right less and curious more and finally
to realize that the prerequisite of the
powers of reasoning is the
responsibility of empathy compassion and
humility
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
perhaps one of the most important but
difficult parts of learning is engaging
in a wide range of topics and books that
oppose our default views
investing many hours into a book that
argues for things you don't necessarily
agree with can understandably be
somewhat unappealing because of this
however many of us can find ourselves in
increasingly isolated echo chambers of
ideas and beliefs but the experience of
confirmation bias is not a sign of
having learned anything truer rather
experiences of realizing you are wrong
is likely a much better sign the book
summary app blinkist helps provide us
with a way out of our echo chambers and
into a more versatile comprehensive and
effective learning habit by taking the
best non-fiction books pulling out the
key takeaways and forming them into
15-minute text and audio summaries that
can be read or listened to even while
offline blinkist allows the average
person to engage in roughly 30 times the
amount of books and the same amount of
time it takes to read just one if you
read just one complete book a month over
50 years you would read 600 books with
blinkist however you could learn from up
to 18 000 books without spending any
additional time the transformation in
who you would become and how you would
understand the world is obvious
currently blinkist has over 5000 titles
in 27 categories as well as summaries of
popular podcasts and a wide selection of
audio books meaning there's essentially
something for everyone in every form if
you're interested in exploring the
subtle delicate art of decision making
why rationality is not always the
guiding force of our so-called rational
choices and how we can hopefully make
better decisions more often blinkist
offers an amazing summary of
psychologist daniel kahneman's
masterpiece thinking fast and slow
use the link in the description and
you'll receive one free week of
unlimited access as well as 25 off of
premium membership the free seven day
trial can be canceled at any time within
the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
[Music]